so Catherine in the movie you attempt
the Benoit Blanc accent have you been
able to nail it since then can either of
you do it
Benoit blanc no clearly
please turn that into a meme
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh that's Southern drawl
ladies and gentlemen
a little bit I'm gonna stop right there
I'm very bad at dumb things kicking
boxes running around searching all the
rooms well this is for Halle Berry
any questions
Halle Berry
that has a kick I can't do it either
come on
Vlog oh that's good
has a way about how he moves his mouth
right yes right right
the trick is the the side mouth because
he he talks out of the side of his mouth
pancaked
shut up shut up with that Kentucky Fried
Foghorn Leghorn draw there's a scene
there's a thing that got cut when I'm
giving everybody their drinks out I say
like what what will you have and he says
what have you got and I said I have
everything and Daniel just made up a
drank he he he goes oh the neck is I'll
have a shot to the Cristo paste
I don't think it's a movie because I
think everybody laughs so hard Daniel
didn't even get through it he said
start going like that and um I got the
outtake of it and I made it my when
Daniel calls me I I I've got it as my
ringtone
play it was like oh you would sufferable
buffoon
[Laughter]
there's some moments this Daniel is pure
comedy yeah he's really really funny
Daniel's a lot more blank than he is
Bond I think yes
considerably
[Music]